Welcome to our Wednesday weekly webinar
we're really happy to see all of you
here
my name is Julie Garden Robinson and
I'll serve as a moderator today I'm a
food nutrition specialist on campus at
NDSU and today's speaker will be Holly
Mobby and I'll be introducing her
shortly I have a couple notes of
introduction before we begin
first of all I'd like to invite you to
upcoming webinars next week we'll have a
session on the food safety modernization
act and it will be led by Dr Kim kolk he
is participated in a lot of Advanced
Training on fisma so if you're even
thinking that someday you might have to
be following fisma guidelines please
take this opportunity to talk to or to
hear from someone who's had a lot of
training in that area
on the 12th of April we'll be hearing
from Dr McGinnis and she'll provide an
update on spotted wings asophila
following that on the 19th of April for
the spring is flying by how to tan low
and high acid foods will be provided by
Dr Clifford Hall who's a professor in
plant Sciences at NDSU and rounding out
this series of 10 webinars will be Todd
weinman and he'll provide an
introduction of Youth to gardening so a
very important thing that we all can do
is to get this love of gardening down
through the younger kids
a few Logistics if you haven't
participated in one of these webinars
before and if you have bear with me a
couple minutes
um you're all familiar
here with the screen now because I've
had you raising your hand and so on if
you have questions along the way you can
go ahead anywhere along the line to type
your question into the chat pod that's
that little white area usually on the
left of your screen or it is on mine and
we'll try to track that so that we
answer your questions as you go
and we will have time allotted at the
end of the webinar for any questions and
answers and of course I'm sure Holly
would be okay with you following up
afterwards uh one special plea from
Julie here and that's to fill out the
short survey at the end of the webinar
and that will be emailed directly to
your email account where you receive
updates on attending this so you've
probably received a little reminder
you'll get a reminder to take the survey
and it'll take you two minutes and I've
got some neat prizes to um help entice
you to take that survey
and now I am very pleased to welcome our
speaker I have a few notes about her so
I'd like to tell you a little bit about
Holly Rose Mobby
she is the director of the
entrepreneurial center for Horticulture
at Dakota College of Bottineau she also
is the executive director of the North
Dakota farmers market and growers
association a past president and current
editor of the North Dakota Horticultural
Society and co-owner along with her
husband Barry and Son Adam of garden
Waller's Farm
this is North Dakota's only culinary
Herb Farm and it sells to grocery stores
restaurants and individuals across North
Dakota and into Minnesota
Garden dwellers Farm has been delivering
fresh cooking herbs and education to
Consumers for 15 years so with that
welcome Holly and thank you for doing a
webinar for us today
thanks Julie that's really nice of you
to absolutely really nice to be here we
have such a nice group of folks with us
today so I'm kind of excited to tell
everyone about the opportunity in
growing herbs
uh this first slide here is my son and I
in our high tunnel filled with uh basil
and right now the high tunnel doesn't
look like that it's just a black dirt
but it has been tilled and it's
anxiously awaiting
um some seeds
growing your old herbs can be a great
way to enhance your home cooking or it
can be a way to create additional sales
for your agriculture-based business
herbs are a niche market so you have to
know that you have the right place to
sell them or the right Market to Market
to If you're looking at adding them to
your agriculture business
but they certainly even if you are not
selling at a farmer's market or pick
your own or through a CSA they certainly
are a great way to enhance your home
cooking and they have great nutritional
value as well besides your cooking
there's a lot of other ways that you can
grow and use herbs in your everyday life
some of them besides the cooking include
of course pea and beverages there are a
lot of herbal teas on the market right
now to kind of give you ideas on what
can be used but many of those things you
see in those pea mixes can be grown on
your own
there are of course medicinal herbs that
can be used in cosmetics in in bath
bombs and facials and soaps and all
sorts of cosmetic items just for the
aroma itself such as potpourri's or even
we often have people buy Bunches of
Basil from us just to take home and put
them in a base and put them on their
counter because the the smell is so
lovely and of course just the beauty and
Aesthetics whether that is the beauty of
growing them in your garden because they
are quite beautiful or using them around
the home such as
Reeds or door swags or decorations so
there's many uses for herbs
that you can grow quite easily
some of the common herbs that we think
of most often of course are basal stage
Thyme and cilantro and that's what's
represented in the pictures here the
upper left with my hands that of course
is basil to the right of that is Sage
below the sage is the cilantro and to
the left of that is time so kind of
working clockwise wise around that
picture you know it's quite interesting
because right now
um where I'm at South of rugby close to
Esmond we still have lots of snow and
and there are places where there are
three or more feet of snow on the ground
still and we're just starting to get a
little bit of open space and and bear
dirt back again but in my production
field the sage and the time
um because they were green and with the
straw mulch like you see in the picture
underneath the snow they tended to warm
up a little bit faster than the
surrounding uh bare dirt and so they are
out there up and looking good and sage
and time are actually perennial they
will come back year after year and
they're also evergreen or semi Evergreen
so if I wanted to today I could walk out
and pick some nice fresh sage and Thyme
and add them to my supper tonight which
is is kind of a
added bonus to having that really early
green stuff in your garden is being able
to taste that right away in the spring
other common herbs again starting from
the upper left you might think that's
Dill but it's not that's actually fennel
leaf many times when we're cooking with
fennel we think of the fennel bulb
fennel bulbs are a little bit more
difficult to do here in North Dakota
because they take such a long season it
can be done but they're long season but
it's on a leaf will add just as much
flavor to your cooking and Aroma and
they make a really nice filler flower in
arrangements so we grow a fair amount of
fennel Leaf here at the farm to the
right of that is the Rosemary our
Rosemary plugs should be coming in on
Friday so I'll have Rosemary to
transplant on Saturday
below the Rosemary in the lower right is
a Greek oregano it's another perennial
the Greek oregano is and that also is
out in the field up green looking good
and if I wanted to make some spaghetti
sauce this weekend which I think I just
might I could run out and pick some
fresh green oregano in the left and the
lower left is mint of course and mint
has many many uses uh in cooking and
around the home and in Aesthetics
so there are a few general rules when
growing herbs that kind of go across the
board no matter what variety you're
growing most of them like Sunny
locations
and if you think about herbs and there
and their purpose and what they're like
we like herbs because they smell and
they taste good and they smell and they
taste good because they have a high
amount of oil in them and the more sun
that herb has the more concentrated that
oil is going to become within the herbs
so it's going to have better flavor and
it will actually do much better in Sunny
locations for most herbs most herbs also
like well-drained soil no mint really
kind of likes a moist soil not soggy but
moist it certainly likes its share of
water but other than the mint most of
them really on the dry side is fine for
most of them
most herbs do not need large amounts of
fertilizer or need to be fertilized
again going back to you know what
doesn't kill us makes us stronger and
it's the oil in the herb that we want to
be very concentrated to give it the best
flavor and Aroma and you will get that
in uh in a plant that is struggling just
a little bit and we certainly don't want
to plant them in hard pan clay but you
you don't need to worry about too much
fertilizer either
um there are a lot of herbs that are
well suited for containers so if you
don't have a spot in your garden or a
production lot or a large space and you
just want to add them to containers on
your deck or your patio there are many
many varieties out there that are well
suited to container growth
some of the myths or semi myths that are
out there about growing herbs is that
most herbs should be picked right away
in the morning right after the duo is
gone
um
while I agree with that and it's a semi
miss for you know I agree with it to a
certain degree it's not always true what
you do want to avoid
is the heat of the afternoon you know
don't go out on a 100 degree day when
the sun is blasting down on things and
pick the herbs then because they are
very much like us plants are
um they have stoma they open and in the
same way we sweat they transpire and
along with that moisture leaving the
plant will be that oil that I've been
talking about that gives it good flavor
and
um good aroma so picking them when it's
a little cooler whether that's in the
morning or in the evening is fine to
stay away from that heat of the day
there's another myth out there that says
oh you know it's it's blooming so I
can't I can't eat it or it's not going
to taste as good
honestly most herb flowers are edible we
make a Great Sage pesto with sage
flowers when it's In Bloom here and it
really would take an extremely refined
palette
um to for a person to taste the
difference between an herb that was
celery and one that was not
so if you keep harvesting of course it's
going to delay that flowering but
actually if if you've gone on vacation
and you come home and you find that your
herbs oh my goodness while I was gone
they started flowering don't let that
stop you go ahead continue harvesting
and using and eating those herbs anyway
um and the last one at downright live
when using the followers pick them
before they're fully open honestly they
will have a a better flavor if you pick
them a little bit more in blood stage
with any flour the longer it's open the
more it declines
um and and loses bigger and flavor so if
you are going to eat the flowers
um actually eating them or picking them
choosing them when they're on the more
of a bud stage is better
excuse me
um so growing herbs for season long
sales what you need to consider is you
will need to plant them in succession
a lot of times people with our other
garden plants our Flowers and Things
They go out and we plant our Marigolds
in the spring and that lasts us all
season long and that's great but if you
are actually in the business of growing
herbs for sale you're probably going to
want especially culinary herbs you're
probably going to want them to plant
them in succession in other words you're
going to plant the seeds or the plants
more than one time and this is
specifically true of annual herbs not so
much The Perennial ones but annual herbs
and we're talking about the basil Dill
cilantro
those sorts of herbs that are very
fleshy they grow very fast and you want
them to be nice and succulent
keeping records is extremely important
and those records will help you from
year to year remember okay I planted my
first basil seeds on May 15th and I
planted the next seeds three weeks later
and oh guess what that was a little too
close together maybe I should move them
now everyone's growing situation is a
little bit different so it's extremely
important that you keep records of your
own plantings so you can gear it towards
your microclimate and your soil
um one of the things I like to express
to people is don't over buy seeds
although most herb seeds will last
several years without losing a great
amount of germination power
it really is unnecessary it adds
unnecessary expense to your bottom line
to over buy those seeds
we did you know for years I've over
bought seed and I've carried seed over
from years year to year but this last
year and I'm we really couldn't get a
couple of our varieties to grow to save
my soul I kept succession planting and
succession planting and they just were
not doing well and finally I kind of ran
a germination test on the seat I was
using and looked at the package and went
well no wonder it's a couple years old I
ordered fresh seed and for the rest of
the season we did fine so I really would
um suggest ordering only the seeds that
you need for a year
with herbs you will always have a time
when you must either find an alternate
use for them or compost them it's the
nature of things
I prefer when I can to find an alternate
use for them of course you know at the
end of the season we might have a whole
lot of Basil left over it's just been
that kind of a good growing Year I'll go
out you know gather bunches and make up
a lot of pesto and freezes there are
some of our other herbs that I'll gather
together and make wreaths for around the
house or sell them at local trade shows
or craft fairs give them away for gifts
we've done that a lot we've gone out and
harvested at the end of the season
everything we could before the first
first Frost and dried them and made all
sorts of holiday gifts with them but if
you can't do that you're going to end up
composting them it's just kind of the
nature of the way it goes you end up
with more green matter than you can
then you can take care of or find a
market for
so being creative and finding those new
markets for leftovers in the field is
really important and being creative you
may be like us
growing and selling culinary herbs or
cooking herbs but you might just find
yourself at the end of the season or the
middle of the Season making some
potpourri or making some other products
so that you are using what you're
growing to the best Advantage for you
and your business
when you're looking at season long sales
you might find that it's not profitable
to begin your sales until your biggest
seller is ready and I'll give you an
example of that with Garden dwellers
Farm our biggest seller is basil and
although as I mentioned I have stage and
Thyme and oregano out there that are
looking good and you all if you've grown
them before you know that those chives
are going to be up and looking good in a
few weeks here you know so we would have
product to sell in a matter of two to
three weeks
our biggest seller is basil and that
will be ready
for another month and a half to two
months and and so it's just not worth
our time and the travel to get to our
markets
um it's not profitable for us to begin
our sales for the year or for this
season until our biggest seller is ready
so you want to capitalize on the season
of the year that works out best for your
production methods and your crops
you can also use your herbs as an ad on
sale to other products or someone else's
and it's a great way to increase your
profits when we were selling at farmers
markets we love uh being next to the the
big produce vendor next to us because we
would talk to them and say okay what's
coming into season next week and they
say oh next week is going to be the
first week for broccoli so you can bet
but that next week we would have a
recipe along with us for broccoli and
some herb or you know we'd have a recipe
for corn and corn and tarragon when that
came into season and always playing off
of what else is in the market can
increase your sales another way to do
that would be if you are maybe growing
and selling
[Music]
um
home decorations like swags and wreaths
and things like that many herbs have
dual uses you might only be doing the
the home craft or home decorations but
Anna's hiccup is also a great tea herb
and maybe your neighbor or someone else
at the market is is selling dried tea
mixtures and you can work with them to
sell them your product that they could
make into theirs or maybe there's
somebody that's making soap and and they
want mint in their silk so work with
others around you for those add-on sales
or those additional sales that you can
use your product in more ways than maybe
what you're just focusing on
so
um if that's your goal remember to focus
on only those that are are well known
easy to grow and easy to sell it's
difficult sometimes with herbs that are
going to give you trouble
to to get them to grow and make them
extremely marketable
I do want to say a little bit about
medicinal herbs I getting away from
medicinal herbs most medicinal herbs
have not had clinical trials
and you use all herbs at your own risk
some herbs can have adverse reactions
with other medications standardized
doses have not been set for herbs and so
you're never sure if you are taking too
much or too little
the potency of herbs can vary greatly
depending upon the growing conditions
and the environment these are some of
the reasons that I personally have kind
of stayed away from the medicinal herb
Market I really encourage you to have a
great level of knowledge in education if
you're going into that area
however there are a few herbs that have
been
scientifically proven to to be of health
benefit
echinacea is one it goes to the immune
system garlic is good for the heart and
cholesterol ginseng is also good for the
heart St John's Wort Ginkgo and parsley
Believe It or Not which contains very
high levels of iron they've all been
proven to be a benefit to your health so
I I encourage you if you are going into
the medicinal herb area to have a great
amount of Education a great amount of
knowledge do your scientific research
um and be very careful about any claims
you might make we don't want to be out
there
um making false claims with anything
that we're selling
and when we're talking about the
culinary herbs the cooking herbs we know
from TV and magazines and and all of the
media around us that cooking at home and
being more adventurous in your cooking
is really
grown in popularity lately people are
are maybe doing a bit more home cooking
than they used to and and they're
getting more adventurous so they're
trying new herbs and new things on the
left hand side I have a list of of the
common culinary herbs basil Sage thyme
rosemary garlic or chives Savory parsley
oregano margarine and cilantro which of
course goes well with almost any tomato
based dish
on the right hand side are maybe those
that are not quite as common
um but they are still they have great
value in The Culinary World fennel as I
mentioned we use the the leaf instead of
a bulb lemon balm or lemon gravina is
not only good with chicken and fish it's
also great in teas and as hiccups cakes
and candies and also tea Stevia
um that's come on the market and gotten
very popular within the last
oh
seven eight years
um it's on the market it has Truvia the
natural sweetener and you'll see a lot
of stevia's that can be grown from seed
and actually does quite well here in
North Dakota as an annual
calendula is often thought of as a
flower in your flower beds very easy to
grow but the petals are great we have
some wonderful recipes for cookies and
and baked goods with the calendula and
the petals add wonderful colors to
salads
nasturtiums if you've never eaten an
assertion again which is thought of as a
flower in your flower bed but if you've
never eaten the leaves or the flowers
themselves I really encourage you to try
them they have a wonderful peppery
flavor to them
um that that adds just so much to a
fresh salad not only the color of the
flowers but also the leaves themselves
celery act if you like celery boy you
can add celery act to just about
anything
same with lovage it has that kind of
celery sort of flavor
mint any any of the mints of course and
then tarragon those would be some but
that are a little bit more Uncommon and
might not if you were selling themselves
quite as well as the list on the left
hand side but certainly would be easy to
grow offerings that you could have as
part of your sales
so a little bit more about some of those
easy to grow ones basil it is an annual
it grows from seed
some people buy basil plants I honestly
don't see the need to do that basil seed
is very inexpensive and it grows really
fast you do want to make sure that you
have a ground temperature of 55 degrees
or more but if your ground is nice and
warm and you put that seed in you'll see
some seedlings popping through within
two to three days that's how fast it is
and so that's why I guess I've never
seen the need to purchase basil plants
it is an annual and it is very Frost
sensitive so you want to make sure all
danger of frost is passed in the spring
and that you do everything you can do
with it before the first Frost in the
fall
time most times are perennial
here at Garden dwellers Farm I like to
plant a variety called German winter
time
during the winter time has proven itself
to be not only the most flavorful of the
varieties but also the most reliably
hearty you know Winters so I like that
kind there's lots of different kinds of
time out there though everything's from
creeping to woolly time to to other
taller white blooming varieties
stage it's also a perennial but I do
have a question mark there because I
have in extreme Winters with no
um
snow cover I have lost sage plants and
they tend to only get three years uh
yeah around three years out of a stand
of sage so I kind of plan every third
year as a new planting of sage so even
though it does make it through the
winter most years for me
um you know I I do plan every couple of
years to rejuvenate that bed just
to be sure I have it on hand
winter savory is one that it's not very
common in cooking you will see just the
word Savory uh different recipes will
just call for Savory there are two kinds
of savory there's summer Savory and
winter savory the winter savory is
listed at the half hearty perennial but
my winter savory comes through every
year I mean it's just for me at least
has been hearty as heck and shows up all
the time
um I see we had a question about in your
comments about replacing this age every
couple years is that in your high Towers
my high tunnels are outside that's
outside the only thing we put in our
high tunnel is uh basil because it likes
it warm and that's one way we can get a
jump on the season is to put the basil
in the high tunnel and I will also put
some about half of the Rosemary I grow
in there
um only because my Rosemary plugs come
in so early in the season that I just
don't have a lot of room in the house
for them so I end up putting about half
of them out into the high tunnel um
that's the only thing we grow in there
the rest of our herbs we put out in the
field so they're they're out in the
field
so the winter savory to go back to that
is a really well behaved uh plant a nice
sturdy stocks
um it's a hearty for me reliably hearty
for me has a good peppery flavor to it
great whenever a recipe calls for Savory
um it's very tidy it stays in a nice
round ball and it doesn't Runner all
over and and very well behaved in in my
garden and my production laws Giants of
course also perennial and you can also
get garlic chives
they grow very fast very early very
reliably Hardy
parsley is truly a biennial which means
that the first year is going to put out
a lot of greens and the second year it's
going to try and go to flower or seed in
our area we grow it as an annual in
other words we till it under at the end
of that first year because in my
experience when it comes back that next
year you're not going to get a lot of
leaf off of it it's going to try and go
to seed right away now if you're seed
savings you may want to keep some of
those around that second year to collect
that seed
if you your goal is the leaves
themselves treat it as an annual and
grow it from seed my parsley seed I put
out as early as I can in fact as soon as
my production lot out there the snow is
gone and the soil is dry enough to work
I put the parsley seed out there even if
I know it's going to frost several more
times I still go ahead and plant because
parsley can take a frost and and not
have any issues with that and so by
planting it really early like that
that's one less thing I have to think
about planting later on
parsley also takes up to 20 21 days to
come up from feed so it's going to take
its darn sweet time so I I get that in
as early as possible
I talked about the winter savory the
summer Savory is an annual in comparison
to its winter savory cousin which is a
perennial so an annual you would as an
annual you would want to seed it every
year and that I also grow from seed oh
that one's not quite as pretty it tends
to fall over in the wind it doesn't have
quite as strong as stems and it does
have a bit of a different flavor from
the winter savory but it still has that
has a very good flavor and is still very
good for cooking and the last uh one on
this slide is lemon balm it's a relative
of the mint family
um I have found it again to be kind of
half hearty perennial some years it
comes back really good for me and other
years it doesn't kind of depends on how
much snow we've had how cold it got
um the good thing about lemon balm is it
does grow really easy from seed so if
you have some seed packets or a seed
packet that you can pick up for lemon
balm it really you can replace it quite
quickly if you were counting on it to
come back over the winter and it didn't
some of the culinary herbs that are more
of a challenge
are Rosemary I've mentioned Rosemary
several times already and I've mentioned
that I I get in clubs or little plants
they're little rooted cuttings is what
they are
Rosemary is not Hardy in North Dakota
and so you need to either bring your
plants inside if you have them in a
container or if you're growing them on a
larger scale you need to replant them
every year
you can purchase Rosemary seed and it's
not that hard to get it to germinate to
come up
but after it germinates it just seems to
languish and sit there and I haven't had
really good luck out of all the years
I've tried
um to get it to push past that initial
germination point to really end up with
a good looking rosemary plant so
um I just go ahead and order limited
cuttings another way that you could do
that would be if you had a place to to
overwinter in your home or or a
greenhouse a large Rosemary mother plant
you could take cuttings because they do
root quite easily from cuttings
Lavender is another one that I know
we've all seen in our seed catalogs
those beautiful pictures of the rows of
lavender and oh how pretty it is
lavender really is not fully hearty in
our area I know Sage burden herbs up in
Manitoba they'll tell you they can get
their their lavender to overwinter just
fine
um they really know some secrets and
some tricks because I've never been able
to get the lavender to to reliably over
winter I'll put in a row of 50 foot roll
and maybe
10 plants will come back and that's all
so it's not really reliable however
that said there are some varieties out
there that you can purchase seed for
that we can treat as an annual one such
variety the variety name is Lady
and you can grow that from seed and get
it to bloom quite well in one season
it's going to be later in the season
before it blooms but if you're looking
for those blossoms to use in potpourried
or in soap so that sort of thing and
you're counting on them to be ready in
the fall you should be able to manage
that
we've all seen or heard of using bay
leaves in cooking that needs to be a
house plant it is a a tree or shrub-like
bush it needs to be started from
cuttings so you know if you want to have
some bay leaves around you can treat
that as a house plant in the winter move
it outside in the summer and you can
have bay leaves which is kind of cool
fennel I've talked about that several
times you know we don't do the bulbs
there are some folks in North Dakota
especially the southern part Bismarck
Mandan Jamestown Fargo that can get some
fairly decent sized fennel bulbs in one
season but up here in the North Country
Bottineau rugby up in our area it's just
really difficult to get any bulb of any
size but the fennel leaves are awesome
tasting
um and if you're not going for that
crunch of the bulb you're just going for
the flavor that always is pretty easy to
grow
oregano and marjoram they are very
closely related plants
that's why you'll see both of them quite
often in in Italian cooking or in
cooking that has maybe a tomato base to
it they both grow really well here my
one caution and this is why they're on
this slide as being more of a challenge
is because they are so closely related
and there are so many varieties
it's difficult to find a good culinary
variety an example of that is I grow two
kinds I grow Greek original and I grow
Italian oregano
and I had always sourced my Italian
oregano from one place and one year I
thought you know I'm ordering Rosemary
plugs from this other Greenhouse maybe
I'll just go ahead and order the Italian
oregano at the same time from the same
place and I got it in and even though
they called it Italian oregano it was
not the same variety it was not exactly
the same plant and that that 280 plants
of Italian oregano that I was looking
forward to ended up being more like the
Greek oregano and just really didn't
have the flavor I was looking for so you
really have to know what you're ordering
paste it if you can see it smell it and
be very familiar with what you want
before you order it because there's lots
of varieties out there that are not the
best flavor
lemon balm as I mentioned may not
overwinter and then tarragon only being
a challenge because it's hearty here
it's a perennial it grows quite large
it'll take off and just be crazy all
summer long and that
is probably the challenge is that it can
get quite large but it can sucker or
Runner itself out and not be the nicest
guest in your garden
um and so it's it's a little bit more of
a challenge only in that way it grows
like crazy and it is a perennial
um you want the French tears on for
cooking that's the kind there's Russian
and there's french you want the French
but it it is quite um
prolific
so harvesting storing and using your
herbs
you can dry them I recommend drying them
in a in an oven if you do it that way
you want them to be at 100 degrees or
lower
um as low as it will go until they're
very crispy
some people if they have a gas oven they
will not turn the oven on at all they'll
just use the ambient heat of the pilot
light
in the oven it takes longer of course to
do it that way and you don't want to
forget that they're in there when you go
to make supper that night but
the lower temperature that you can dry
them at
the less chance you will have of cooking
them
instead of drying them because the
purpose is to remove that moisture that
water out of the plant without removing
those oils that give it its good flavor
so the lower temperature you can go the
better
an alternative way to to store them or
to preserve them is to hang dry them
very easy simply just um you know Bunch
them together in in small bunches not
too big a bunches
and with a a clip or a rubber band and
hang them in a warm dark place Out of
the Dust until they're dry
now if you live in the country or on a
gravel world like I do and you say now
that's great but we're really dusty
around here you can put a paper bag over
them to kind of keep the dust off which
is a nice way to do that as well
excuse me
um you can freeze them and this happens
to be one of my favorite ways to do this
because it's quicker
to me it seems easier when I freeze my
herbs I rough chop them
so in other words they're bigger pieces
not teeny tiny pieces
put them in an ice cube tray fill the
ice cube tray up with water or butter or
oil depending on how you're going to use
them later and I put them in the freezer
and once they're frozen I pop them out
of that ice cube tray I put them in a
freezer bag an appropriate Ziploc
freezer bag and label them because once
they're in ice cube steak they all kind
of look alike green little cubes so make
sure that you label them with what they
are and pop them back in the freezer the
interesting or the nice thing about
doing it this way is an ice cube tray
once you've added some water it's pretty
much equivalent to like a tablespoon
depending on your ice cube tray a
tablespoon or two tablespoons which is
just about right for a lot of your
recipes so it comes up being really
convenient in the end
um
if you're going to dry them whether you
dry them in the oven or you're hang dry
them
when you are storing them you want to
keep them as low or as whole as possible
until you use them when you start to
crush them up and crumble them up you
are you're releasing those oils and
again that's what gives it its flavor
and I thought it was interesting because
within the last several months
um the the very well-known and large
seasoning manufacturer McCormick has
started that that Trend now they've
really started that marketing push to
say you know we're putting everything we
have in Grinders now because the more
whole it is the better it is
Suzanne has asked a question about
dehydrators
dehydrators are great again you want to
make sure your dehydrating hydrating
them at a low temperature 100 degrees or
under
and and then dehydrators yes of course
work wonderfully
herbal teas are really uh they're good
for you they are low in calorie higher
in nutrients and they just taste darn
good some of the common herbs or teas or
drinks are of course the mint
the hiccups if you're not familiar with
yourself it has kind of a licorice
flavor so if you like licorice
um you might want to consider some of
the hiccups I particularly like anise
Jacob
which has a beautiful purple flower and
works well as a substitute for lavender
Bergamot or bee balm Lemon Verbena lemon
balm chamomile and lemon basil are all
wonderful in herbal teas lavender or
Hound Beaver Pew Angelica sweet grass or
lemongrass and rose hips are all common
herbs that you can grow we don't often
think of roses as an herb but they are
um
the hips of course are actually seeds
not the third part of the plant
but they fall into that herb category
lemongrass or sweet grass is one that
you will want to have in a pot so you
can take it in the house because to get
the good
base or bulbous end of the plant
um which is what's best for tea
you will want to have a very long season
or or keep them as a houseplant
this is a picture of annasop I mentioned
that it works really well as alternative
to Lavender and you can kind of see that
in this picture this is a bunch that I
had harvested for some tea way back in
2004 they use we looked at that
beautiful purple color isn't that
gorgeous it also looks really good in
the flower bed can you imagine how
beautiful that would look next to other
colorful flowers yellows oranges it
really is a standout in the garden it
tends to be for the most part perennial
again like lemon balm if if we have one
of those really bad Winters you may lose
it but it grows really well from seed
and for most cases will be perennial for
you but it's about two and a half feet
tall and is really pretty in my opinion
what is what a nice addition to either
of the flower garden herb garden Olive
vegetable garden
when you're making herbal tea we do not
recommend sun tea because leaving things
out
what a great way to grow bacteria let's
take some moisture and put it in the sun
where it's warm and and leave it there
so I don't recommend something the best
way to gather is gather your herbs put
them in a cheesecloth bag or a tea
holder boil your water separate and then
pour the water over the tea leaves don't
put them all together then you're going
to let it steep for three to five
minutes depending on what you like to
taste and then enjoy
one note here though currently in North
Dakota is not allowed by the State
Health Department or any of the local
Health districts to actually sell the
beverage tea
at farmers markets or other markets
however you could make the tea bags with
the dried tea
and sell those
of course you can make all sorts of Home
Cosmetics bath disease that's soaking
soaking bags lotions soap massage and
Body Oil
um all of those things can be made very
easily with your herbs and the recipes
are all over the Internet so you know
it's not something I'm going to spend
time going into here
um but but that's a potential Outlet or
a potential market for herbs that you
could be growing at home
herbs just for the aroma Sweet Annie is
a type of Artemisia that grows very tall
five to six feet tall has a beautiful
golden color in the fall and it makes
great wreaths and swags and decorations
um lavender as I mentioned we talked
about that heliotrope has a very vanilla
scent and there's another purple flower
you can find that in your local
nurseries and garden centers
Bergamot is a is also bee balm and is
wild around here Artemisia or wormwood
and I see we have Michelle has asked any
of these herbs repel insects like box
elder bugs
now the Sweet Annie and the wormwoods
have been said to repel insects and in
fact I used to sell a fair amount of the
Sweet Annie and wormwood in Reeves when
we were in Minnesota
um to people that had cabins because
they would put them in their cabins to
keep kind of the the spiders and the
bugs out over winter
um the Patchouli that's listed on this
slide Lemon Verbena and rosemary all
kind of have that same
um
insecticidal properties to them but you
know I'll be real honest and say you
know some people say basil oil does the
same thing repels flies
I will sit in my high tunnel surrounded
by thousands of basil plants and be
covered with insects so you know I think
it uh
there's room for improvement on any of
these
but if I had to
recommend trying any of these for
repelling insects it would be the Sweet
Annie and any of the artemisions
and the patchouli
and maybe they're Rosemary
uses for aromatic herbs stewing herbs if
you're not familiar with storing herbs
that they used to when they had
dirt floors they would they would put
the herbs down on the floor and walk on
them to make it smell good in the house
of course potpourri wet or dry sachets
for your closets and and in amongst your
Linens and your towels and of course
I've mentioned wreaths and swags many
times
some herbs to think about winter savory
chives still basil Sage Bergamot lemon
balm thyme Anna take up and the mint
when you can contain them because they
will get away from you they like to
crawl and be friendly with other places
um but those are kind of my favorites
and if I had to choose what to start
with that would be my list of where to
start my least liked herbs comfrey
chicory oregano only because it's like I
mentioned it's tough to get a good
tasting one
um mints when they're not contained when
you can't keep them where they belong
they're not my favorite some are Savory
I mentioned it's just not pretty it's
it kind of Falls over in the winds and
the cilantro only because it's a
challenge to keep cilantro from bolting
In the Heat of the summer and here's the
cilantro I know we're running out of
time but I just want to take a couple of
minutes to talk about
um the cilantro to do it well
you need to plant cilantro in succession
here at the farm we plant cilantro every
two weeks
and it only gets
six inches tall and we're cutting it and
it only lasts two to three weeks and
then we take that whole room out
because once it gets hot once we start
getting into the heated summer the first
thing it's going to want to do is form
flowers and seeds
and that's not what you're planning it
for you're planning it for that
wonderful aromatic Leaf to use in that
summer salsa with those home grown
tomatoes
um so my suggestion people ask me very
often how do I grow good cilantro my six
suggestion is to just keep planting it
every two to three weeks Deb says that
her cilantro gets bugs now honestly I
have never had my cilantro get bugs if
if you happen to know what kind of bug
it gets please let me know because then
I could probably give you a suggestion
on what to do about that
um
but I've never had that issue so I'm I'm
not sure what kind of bug would be
bothering it although it is kind of in
the same family as the parsleys and some
of the monarch butterfly
caterpillars may like it
here's just kind of a list of things
that we grow I've talked about all of
these throughout the presentation in in
different forms
um
just giving you a lift to maybe kind of
uh spark your interest in growing
something new or something different or
going down an Avenue for add-on sales or
for sales for your home agricultural
business
when harvesting as I mentioned avoid the
heat of the day
you want to cool down the herbs as
quickly as possible
high humidity is the key to Fresh long
lasting herbs you do not want them wet
just in kind of a humid environment
most herbs will regrow for a second
cutting within two weeks so plan to
plant twice what you need if you're
cutting every week if you're taking them
to the farmers market every week
and you think okay I'm going to cut uh
20 feet of cilantro every week to take
to the market then you're going to want
to plant 40 feet
make sure you use clean utensils to help
prevent the spread of disease here is
what it looks like when we are
harvesting our basil
um you know it's kind of backbreaking
work you're down on your hands and knees
I I have a little stool that I use quite
often to sit on and go down the row and
cut we cut each piece each tip by hand
with the basil
and then they get dunked in this cooler
this cooler is full of
fairly cold water we don't want it ice
cold but but you want cool water what
you are trying to do is shock those
stoma into closing first of all and
second of all you're you're taking the
field heat out of those herbs so that it
starts that cooling process
um and then you want to get them we put
them in plastic tubs or totes uh like
you can see there we put the lid on and
we put them in a cool dark place the
plastic totes with the lid on will hold
the humidity in and that's what I was
saying is you want them humid but not
wet
packaging at a farmer's market how you
display and package your herbs that the
market really depends on your Market
customer preferences we like large tubs
with lids
because we again can keep the humidity
up
um but if you're going to package them
because that's what the customers at
your market like
make sure that you package them in a
breathable package and packages closely
to sale time as possible because again
water is the enemy
if you're packaging to wholesale uh to
restaurants or institutions most of them
will take them by the pound or an
increments of a pound half pound quarter
pound and we'll take them in in just a
plain bag a plain clear bag make sure
that you are using
um bags that are specifically for food
and that's what they're intended for
food grade bags are good vented ones
ones with holes in or or a way for air
exchange is our best and purchase the
bag that fits the most usual quantity
you are selling it's what you sell the
most of is a pound then purchase bags
that uh
that will hold a pound and I say this
because again as a business you don't
want to spend a whole lot of money
buying up a bunch of inventory such as
four different sizes of bags
when really you only need one size a bag
to make do for most of your customers
it's going to save your business money
and inventory
um
packaging to retail stores such as
grocery stores is a little bit trickier
you want to visit with them and talk to
them about their expectations
if you were in a grocery store and you
think you want to sell herbs to them
take a look at what they have some
grocery stores just have their herbs
packaged in a clear plastic bag with a
very simple label on it others have them
bunched in bunches that are tied with
rubber bands or twist ties and others
have them in soy or plastic based clam
shells what we call clam shells
the best thing you can do is to look at
at their packaging and mimic things that
as closely as possible
some stores may require you to have a
UPC label or a PLU which is a product
lookup
packaging can be your most expensive
cost in herb sale right after
transportation and distribution and
finding labels and packaging materials
can be really difficult if you're
interested if and you intend on
packaging your product be careful to
have the equipment or facilities
necessary to store it before delivery
and when I say that what I mean is you
know some you put one ounce of herbs in
packages they're going to take up a
whole lot more room
then if they were in
the tubs like I showed earlier
this is a picture of our product on the
grocery store itself you can see that we
do use the plastic clam shells and I
will tell you and we have a UPC label
you can see that down in the lower right
and I can tell you that the packaging
and the labeling of our product
is the the part of our product that
takes the most time and costs us the
most money and so if you really want to
do your homework lay out your business
plan before you go down that road but it
can be very enjoyable
growing organic remember not to use
phrase or chemicals on food products if
you can avoid it if you do need to do
that be sure you're following all of the
label and manufacturer instructions
manure is a wonderful soil conditioner
as well as fertilizer when applied
appropriately so be sure that you
understand the food safety rules for
applying soil amendments and most herbs
are relatively disease and bug free I
can honestly tell you other than
grasshoppers
I've never really had an issue with bugs
on our
herbs at all I know I've done a little
bit over the time for questions asking
but certainly uh would be available
here's our website phone number
um and our Facebook page if you wish to
ask me any questions now or you don't
feel you have time and would like to
come and visit us at our website or our
Facebook page and ask questions later
please feel free to do that
thank you so much Holly that was a very
interesting and I'm sure everyone
enjoyed it we have time for a couple
questions
you can go ahead and type your question
in the box if you are interested
and I'll I'll put the slide back in case
you want to write down Holly's email
here we have a question for you how well
do cold frames work around here they're
in Mandan
I love cold frames they work really well
especially for those things that are
um kind of cold tolerant to begin with
the dill cilantro fennel
um all parsleys of all of those things
are are fairly cold tolerant to begin
with as well as many of The Perennial
ones
if they're also a great way to get as I
mentioned basil likes it warm and while
you wouldn't be able to start basaling
your Cold Frame now you certainly would
be getting a jump on having them planted
in the garden by putting them in a Cold
Frame you could get at least two to
three weeks jump on them that way
next question was how well does Stevia
grow for me Stevia grows really well for
me I the stevia seed is a little bit
expensive
but it's come down a lot in the last
couple years I always start mine from C
I put it out uh in the field and it just
it grows like crazy I mean it gets uh
well 20 to 22 inches tall and if you
pinch it when it's young so that you are
encouraging it to Branch you can get
more branches which of course means more
leaves off of it
um and I've really never had any disease
or insect issues with the stevia at all
I've really had good luck with it
so I will bring our session to a close
even though I think we could go on all
afternoon
thank you again to everybody for
attending today
please fill out the survey that you'll
get the link to
and join us again next week you'll hear
all about spotted windrosophila so there
you go